when you did  a movie like superman three how was that  working with christopher he was  fantastic he was  so kind because i was coming in  i i think i would i think they were just  really angry with margot kenner because  she was causing them some grief i don't  know how or why and she's been the  sweetest you know she came to smallville  and she was so sweet but even then  because i had like a couple of scenes  with her that we shot in one day it  wasn't easy and she was incredible she  was so welcoming  and she was friends with richard pryor  and and she introduced me to him and he  was so kind to me and just we sat on the  satin top and he was so sweet really  yeah what a great moment yeah